so lena heute gehts haus ram bis zu
bereich was für angst ich bin bereit
du hast keine angst ein aber du hast
dann ist es doch eigentlich somit das
krasseste was du machen kannst du nur
draufgänger bin auch gespannt also ich
habe eigentlich keine höhenangst
aber ich habe mir so ein paar videos
dazu angeschaut das sieht schon echt
krass aus denn wenn die leute dann zu
überschauen und es geht aber so sind es
gleich vorstellen ist gar nicht aber es
ist echt krass also ich freue mich auch
so schon spannenden
einfach jesus
max lena veranstaltungen wie eine rose
zur welt
ja
für mich direkt sicher okay ich mache
den anfang mit
max
arbeiten
hmm
ok los geht's
mit ganzen bringen
ich stehe also heftig dieses ist schon
krass
und wenn man über die kante ist krass
also wenn man dann plötzlich da hängt in
den seilen und hören sie abstößt
also es war schon war schon heftig
nicht
ist traurig nicht
als gut
u
in dem song britta gelaufen schaffen
müsste auf unten sehr stark aber es war
cool aber das schiff wahrscheinlich
anfragen als ich halt sagen auf mich
allein gestellt war und ich da hin dass
mir mein gott hat diesen sprung das war
du warst aber auch ca ach so auf der
höhe also 5 milliarden weitere spuren
der letzte sprung war so richtig aber es
war viel verstärkt für es geschafft
trotz höhen hat irgendwie eingespielt
oder am anfang so die china 2
hier ein bisschen dreck den ice stark
okay leute das war dann auch die letzte
folge von action haus ich habe eine
richtig coole woche hinter mir
mit coolen und manchmal nicht so schwarz
mit kühlen gästen auf jeden fall
ich bin mir sicher genauso viel spaß
dabei wie ich und habe ich sagen schau
mach's gut und man sieht sich